did you know you can expand the
relevance of your answers you get from
AI based on the way you ask a question
this is RO prompting for example you are
PK teacher help me explain to my son
what is a universe Ro prompting is to
give the large language model a role to
play in the TX a role could be anything
from a fitness coach a teacher a chef or
maybe a customer service agent this
helps the model to better understand the
con TA of question and give you a more
accurate response for example you're a
travel agent help me book a trip to
Tokyo for 7 Days Beyond improved
accuracy and relevance you can get from
the response there are three other
benefits you can get out of the model
first more informed and nuanced response
second better control over the tone and
output third is a reduce risk of biases